who's the next quarterback for the
steelers let's assume it's one more year
with ben he turned 39 this week i can't
imagine him playing in 2022 but who the
hell knows about anything at this point
who do you think the next guy will be
mike i think it really depends on
whether
mac jones is available when they draft
um and i don't think he will be the
quarterback from alabama i think by the
time the steelers pick in the in the
first round
um that they are going to be they're
gonna be looking at
uh all five quarterbacks having been
drafted already
so then you have to decide if you're the
steelers do we really love
one of the second tier guys a lot
and
should we over pick him with our first
round pick or do we just wait till 2022
the thing about quarterbacks okay
there's not a soul
and look i wrote about zack wilson this
week in my column
and one year ago today
zach wilson was in a three-man
competition for the starting job
at brigham young
and now chris sims thinks he's the best
quarterback in this draft
so you know gonna be picked in the top
three
so so that's why
you can look at
the draft and say well you know this
year is gold for quarterbacks absolutely
gold next year though cupboard's a
little bit bare you simply don't know
zack wilson appeared out of the clear
blue sky
in this year and it's almost the same
thing when you think about it joe burrow
in 2020
you know in 2019 he would have been a
fourth round pick you know would he come
out so
so quarterbacks are going to emerge
and all i'm saying is that if you look
at
uh what the steelers are going to do at
24 as you look at the bottom half of the
round
i just don't think that one of those
five quarterbacks that that everybody
universally
with the exception of chris respectfully
by the way
uh has the top five i don't think any
one of those five guys going to be there
when they pick
chris has kellen monda in that mix as
well to push it to six and you know one
thing the steelers could do and we've
seen them do it three times that i can
remember over the course of the last
generation when they wanted troy
palamala what did they do they traded up
to get him when they wanted san antonio
homes what did they do traded up to get
him two years ago they wanted devin bush
traded up to get him they will move up
if a guy that they love is in striking
distance they're not going to tell us
they love the guy they're
they're gonna wait to make their move
but if if one of these five or six
quarterbacks is a quarterback with whom
the steelers become smitten that's on
the table as well and you know ben could
get pissy sorry london about that
thinking well why aren't you getting me
a weapon i gave up five million dollars
and you're not using the first round
pick on a guy who can come in and help
us win this year but they got to take
care of that situation
peter the last time they they went down
this road franchise quarterback on his
way out they passed on dan marino
because it was going to be awkward dan
marino and terry bradshaw and chuck noll
pushed for gabe rivera because they need
to go defense defense is what made us
who we are and terry bradshaw had minor
elbow surgery under the assumed name
thomas brady in march and he only threw
eight more passes over the course of his
career and they could have had dan
marino so i think that's part of it too
if there's someone they like and he is
available they can't hesitate to either
take him or trade up to get him if they
think they can do it just because ben
may not like it
yeah this is a different story this year
mike because there's no question
in 1983
even though everybody knew that it was
close to the end for
for bradshaw
i think this year when you look at it
you look at a situation where
everybody knows that not only is it
close to the end
for uh you know for for for
roethlisberger but i think most people
including ben himself
would say hey listen
if there's a quarterback that is a
franchise we really like i i don't think
i don't even think ben would give it an
eye roll mike
uh i think he would understand that
there's a good chance this is my last
year and they have to look out for
what's best for the franchise now
of course would he rather have
you know a great wide receiver
potentially at 24 of course
but
i don't really think when i look at this
team with the exception of the drops of
deontay johnson and it was an epidemic
last year it was bizarre to me how how
loyal they were to
a player who just
continued to hurt him week after week as
the season went on
but i just don't see right now wide
receiver even if juju smith schuster
leaves as being a desperate need
position
ben roethlisberger wasn't happy when the
steelers used a third round pick on
mason rudolph a few years ago one year
after they took josh dobbs in the fourth
round
and this is back when ben was doing the
93-7 the fan interviews in pittsburgh he
would do periodically in the off-season
he would do them every week in the
regular season and i missed them because
they were great fountains of
of of of nuggets that we could use and
talk about because he was way too candid
with his thoughts he said i was
surprised they took a quarterback i
thought maybe in the third round you
know you can get somebody who's really
good who can help the team win now
nothing against mason too late for that
so uh yeah i agree i agree with you
though
he can't
he can't well he can be whatever he
wants but
i think it's easier for him to
understand
if anyone even needs to explain it to
him hey ben look a little steelers
history for you it was a long 20 years
between terry bradshaw and you we don't
want to do that again we saw a guy that
we really liked we thought being with
you for a year would benefit him
and that's the other thing they need to
they need to factor into this
is it good
to to have a young guy around ben for
what will be his last year will he truly
take him under his wing will he help him
or will he have just no use for him
whatsoever
because this guy's not helping my goal
of of doing what jerome bettis did and
walk off into the sunset with a brand
new lombardi trophy
you know to me ben is not
your sort of drew brees type tutor
you know like if if you talk to taste
some hill he'll tell you that
he's been a puppy dog around drew brees
for the last two or three years
and brees has helped him legitimately
not helped him take his job
but helped him because the kid works
hard
and and i just i don't see ben
roethlisberger being that way
because i don't think he is one of these
and again i i don't i'm not there so
what do i know i don't think he's one of
these get in at 5 30 in the morning
leave at 8 o'clock at night guys
you know nor do you need to be that way
honestly
but my feeling is i think ben would be
cordial and fine and look
even if he wasn't mike i mean look at
look at the way tom brady reacted to
jimmy garoppolo he wasn't cruel he
wasn't mean he wasn't anything
he was just he was a professional
and and and to me that is what you do if
you're angry at what the team does you
don't take it out on this kid
you know you you you basically just
continue to work hard and as derek jeter
once said about leadership i don't lead
with what i say i lead with what i do
and and that to me is what if you're
jordan love this year
watching aaron rodgers i mean that's the
way you lead you you don't lead by aaron
rodgers going hey jordan stick with me
and and do everything i do it's just
it's natural you just do it that way and
so i don't i don't think ben would be
you know ben would be the great
quarterback tutor but nor do i think he
would be uh you know not inclusive to
the kid
now mac jones here's what you do when
you want to embellish an injury you get
up really slow you move your arm around
like this
right you go to the locker room for a
few minutes just read a newspaper smoke
a cigarette and then come back and
everybody will say wow it's willis reed
i'm kidding i'm kidding and i've got
i've got people behind the curtain who
are bad influences on me if anyone's
upset
i blame them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports